よろしくお願いします
今日はアングッテルニカーへの一つの経典を得ました
日本訳を配ってください
一応訳は後で読んだ方がいいと思いますけどね
というと先に読んじゃうっていうこともありますけど
もう生活に慣れました
アンデスッタンという
あの これ 訳とこれとぴったしがちょっと調べなかったんです
すぐインターネットから今印刷したんだから
もしかするとこの訳は違う経典かもしれません
似てる経典がいくつかありますのでね
あまり大事には言からないでおきます
タヨネーディッカウェープッゲラーサントサンウィッジャナーナーローカスミンカトネータヨーアンドーエーカチャックーディチャックー
カトモーチャディッカウェープッゲローアンドーイデディッカウェーエーカッチャッスプッゲラッス
タタールーパンチャックンノーティヤタールーペーナチャックーナアヌディガタンワーボーガンアディガッチェーヤアディガタンワーボーガンパーティンカレーヤ
これ シンハラ文字でアッファーティカレイヤとひともじりになってます
ヒット言葉に タタールーパンティスチャックーナノーティヤタールーペーナチャックーナ
クシャラクシャレダンメージャーネイヤ
サワッジャーナワンジェーダンメージャーネイヤ
ヒーナッパニテーダンメージャーネイヤ
サンナスクサッパティダージェーダンメージャーネイヤ
アワンウィッチャティディッカウェープッゲローアンドー
まぁ一応何言ってるかわからないんですからね
タヨーメー タヨーメーっていうのは三つありますよと
三人いますよと この場合はディッカウェーっていうのは比丘たちを三人いますよと
プッゲラ 人々が あれ プッゲラっていうのはパーソナリティだから
こちらは三つの類の人がいると
三種類の人がいるんだと
サンウィッジャマーナ
まぁ世の中で ローカスミン
世の中で サンウィッジャマーナ
見られますよと これ お釈迦様がこの世の中で三種類の人々が見られますと
人間を三つに分けちゃうんですね
カトネータヨー この三つは何なのかと
何であろうかと アンドー
一番目 アンドー 盲人 一番目が盲人
二番目が一眼ある人 エーカチャックー
三番目がディチャックー
両眼ある人 それで人々を三つに分けてます
盲人と一眼の人と両眼持っている人と
えーとね そういえばそういう三種類はいますけどね
そこでも決してお釈迦様はこういう差別的な
あの 区別するわけじゃないんです
ですから お釈迦様が盲人と言えば
なんか別な意味であることはもう決まっているんです
まあいつでも仏教の世界で出てくることで
この辞書を引いて出てくる意味で使っているわけじゃないんです
そこでお釈迦様も我々仏教を語っている弟子というか
もう坊主たちもかなり学者に怒られるんですね
辞書の意味に取らないかとか
そういった点はこちら困りますからね
こちらにはそちらの意味があるんだからね
いつでもそういうことが仏教の特徴ですね
世の中で使っている意味では使わない
そこで次に行きます カトモーチャディッカウェープッゲローアンドー
この盲人という人はどのような人でしょうかと
いかなる人のことであろうか
イデディッカウェーエーカッチャッスプッゲラッスタタールーパンチャックンナホーティヤタールーペーナうんうんと
ある人々にこの目はないんだと
このタタールーパヤタールーパっていうのは
この関係代名詞でつなげるんですね
まずこの目がないんだ
このような目がないんだと
それからどのようなことかと次に説明するんですね
この目はないんだと エチャックーナアヌディガタンワーボーガンアディガッチェーヤ
アヌディガタンワーボーガン
ボーガンっていうのは財産
お金とかそういうものですね
財産 アヌディガタンというのは自分がもう儲けてない
得てない 獲得していないんですね
自分が得てない 未だに自分が儲かってない
獲得してないボーガン
財産をアディガッチェーヤ
これから儲かっているところになろうではないかと
これから財産に恵まれ恵まれるではないかという
その目がないんだと ですから
こちらで目っていうのはそのノウハウですよ
このテクニックを持ってないんだと
だから人間っていうのは
まあ財産ある人ない人もいるんだけど
今まで得てない財産っていうのはどういう意味ですかね
より豊かになることなんですよ
一万円持ってるけど 一万円ばっかり持ってると
もうそれで豊かになるわけじゃないんですね
だから 一万円ある人は二万円にすることは
今まで獲得していない財産を得ることになっちゃうんだよね
だから いくらお金すでにあってもなくてもどうでもいいんです
財産があってもなくても
今の状態よりもっと豊かな状態になれるということ
その眼が持ってないと
このテクニック持ってない
そのノウハウを持ってない
その能力がない それが盲人と言ってるんですね
それでまた続けます アディガタンガドーガンパーティーカレーや
アディガタンガドーガン
アディガタンドーガンというのは
自分がもうもうとっくに持っている財産のことなんですね
パーティーカレー屋っていうのは実ることなんですね
自分とっくに 例えば埋まり好きとか
家出とかなんとか財産あるかもしれません
それをもうさらにもう実らしてあげると
パートっていうのは この
まあやっぱり増えること
増やすことなんですね
豊かになることで いわゆる実らせることなんですね
花咲くすることなんですね
持ってる財産にも花咲かせることはできないと
そのノウハウは テクニックはないんだと
タタールーパンティッサチャックモホーティ
また こんなものないんだと
だから人間に目 2つあるんだから
この人盲人でしょ いわゆる 2つもないんですよ
1つの目がないといったことは
一応経済的にはもうダメな人間なんですね
もう全部ダメにしちゃうっていう意味なんですよ
いわゆる経済的に豊かさになる方法わからない
それ 1つの目がない 人間にはその目も必要なんですね
ですから ある面で言っているのは
たとえ商売繁盛のからくりの悪知恵を持っていたっても
それは一目しかないんだという意味なんですよ
その人にもう 1つ目があるんですよ
それもないんだと どういうことかというと
ヤタールーペーナチャックナクソラクソレーダンメージャーネーヤ
クソラダンマっていうのは善
アクソラダンマっていうのは不善
善と不善って何なのかと
それが区別する能力はない
だから 2番目の目もないんだと
サーラッジェアナラッジェダンメージャーネーヤ
サーラッジェダンマっていうのはこの罪ですね
やってはいけないことを法律で捕まれるは
社会的に批判されるは
また地獄に落ちる可能性があるは
善不善よりもちょっときついんですね
まあ悪と良い行為ですね
罪でいいんですね 罪と良いことは区別する能力はないんだと
それからヒーナッパニーテーダンメージャーネーヤ
ヒーナっていうのは卑しい
パニータっていうのは優れている
卑しいものは何なのか
優れ-優れているものは何なのかさっぱりわからない
この人 それは性格のことなんですよ
自分がどんな性格で生きていれば卑しい人間になるか
どんな性格を育てれば優れている人間になるかって
そのノウハウを持ってない
それからカンヌスッカパティバーゲ
カンナっていうのはブラック
スッカっていうのはホワイト
ですから それも善悪のことで
白黒はっきりしないんだと
これも善悪の問題なんですね
道徳的なことで で 白い方
もう黒い方も知らない
白い方も知らないと 真理も知らない
だから番目の目っていうのは
善悪は知らないということなんです
それだけじゃない 卑しい性格
優れている性格も分かってない
それを分かっているならば
人が成長するんだけど
この人にこの業務もないんだと
経済的な能力もないし
道徳的な判断能力もないんだと
ですから 業務もない ですから盲人だと
そういうことで お釈迦様が目が見えない人を差別してるわけじゃないんです
目が見えない人はもういて
一つの目だけ見える人がいて
二つを見える人がいるんだろうとかね
そんなことはどうでもいいことで
こちらが言っているのは
経済的に豊かに 俗世間で豊かになる能力もないし
道徳的な理解 分別する能力もないんだったら
もう盲人だと そこで次に行きます
カトモーチャ・ビッカリ・プッガルー・エーカチャック
エーカチャック えっと
片目  一眼ある人は誰ですか？目一つだけある人は誰ですかと
イダ・ビッカリ・エーカッチャッサ・プッガラッサ・タタールーパン・チャックホーティ
まぁこの目あるんだよと
ヤタールーペーナ・チャックナ
どのような目かというと
アナビガタンワー・ボーガン・アビガッチャイヤ
もう自分にはもうアナビガタンワー・ボーガン
もう得てない財産は もうちゃんと頑張って財産を獲得する
金持ちになる 豊かになる
その目はあるんですよ
こうすれば儲かるんだ
こうすれば儲かるんだと
金持ちに金が手に入るんだよという
その知識はあります それからアビガタンワー・ボーガン・パーティン・カレイヤ
自分がもう得た財産を花咲かせて
さらに増える能力も持っているんだと
しかし タタールー・パッサ・パナッセ
それはタタールー・パン・ピッサというカリもあるみたいですね
まぁどちらでも正しいんですね
タタールー・パン・パナッセ
そのような人なんです
しかし チャック・ナホーティ
ある目がない ヤタールーペー・チャックナ
どのような目かというと
クサラ・クサラ・ダンメー・ジャーネイヤ
善悪の判断できる目は持ってない
サーワッジャーナ・ワッジェ・ダンメー・ジャーネイヤ
間違っているものは何ですか
正しいものは何ですかと
いわゆる罪と あの 善が何なのかと
その区別はわからない
この人は ヒーナッパニーテ・ダンメー・ジャーネイヤ
卑しい特色は何なのか
優れている人格は何なのか
さっぱりわからない カンナ・スッカ・パティバーゲ・ダンメー
それから もう白黒はっきりしない人生というかね
それも性格的に人格的にはっきりしない人生だと
アワン・ウッチャティ・ビッカリ・プッガルー・エーカチャック
その人にあるのは目は一つだけだと
それから両方の目を持っている人のこと
もうとっくにわかっていることで
カトモーチャ・ビッカリ・プッガルー・ディチャック・イダ・ビッカリ・エーカッチャッサ・プッガラッサ・タタールーパン・チャック・ホーティ・ヤタールーペーナ
・チャックナ・アナビガタンワー・ボーガン・アビガッチャイヤ・アビガタンワー・ボーガン・パーティン・カレイヤ・ヤタールーパン・ピッサ・チャック・ホーティ
・ヤタールーペーナ・チャックナ・クサラ・クサラ・ダンメー・ジャーネイヤ・サーワッジャーナ・ワッジェ・ダンメー・ジャーネイヤ・ヒーナッパニーテ・ダンメー
・ジャーネイヤ・カンナ・スッカ・サッパティ・バーゲ・ダンメー・ジャーネイヤ・アワン・ウッチャティ・ビッカリ・プッガルー・ディチャック・イメーコー・ビッ
カリ・タヨー・プッガラ・サントサン・ヴィッジャマーナ・ローカ・スミンティ
で 三番目の人は イダ・ビッカリ・エーカッチャッサ・プッガラッサ
ある人に タタールーパン・チャック・ホーティ・ヤタールーペーナ
このような目がありますよと
アナビガタンワー・ボーガン・アビガッチャイヤ
財産 ない財産をしっかり仕事をして
まあ商売して もう儲けてみる
それからアビガタンワー・ボーガン・パーティ・カレイヤ
ある財産はどんどんどん増やして花咲かせてみるする
それからタタールーパンピースチャック
それだけじゃない もう一つも目があるんだと
タタールーペナチャックーナ
クサラクサラインダンメーダーネイエ
クサラクサラダンマを知ってます
善法 悪法 不善法をちゃんと知っている
善法 不善法 サーワッジャアナワッジーダンメー
間違ってる方 正しい方
ちゃんと知っている 間違ってる真理なん
真理と言えない 法ですね
間違ってる法って何なのか
間違ってる正しいものは何なのかをちゃんと知っている
ヒーナッパミーテーダンメー
卑しいものは何なのか
優れてるものは何なのか
しっかり知っている カンナスッカサッパティバーゲ
えーと 白黒はっきりしている
それもこの即席の白黒ではなくて
道徳的な倫理的な白黒なんですね
ダンメージャーネイエ
アワンニッケティビッケレープッガローディチャック
これは両面のある人だと
イニーコービッケプッガラーサントーサンウィッジャマーナローカッセ
このように三種類の人間がいるんだよと
だから それから質問なんですけど
そういう風に人類はまとめて三つにカテゴライズできますかね
なんか漏れる人々ないんですかね
その三つから え この三つに入らない人々もいますよと
できない あの 財産は増やせないけど
善悪は分かる人いないですか
うん まあそういう疑問が生まれてきますね
財産を増やす能力はないんだけど
善悪判断できると でも問題は
善悪判断できる人はすごい頭がいいんですよ
善悪っていうのは道徳的ではなくて
何がやればいいか 何かやってはいけないかっていうこともだし
だからサーワッジャアナッジー全部入ってますよ
ということは もう次の目を持ってるんだっていうことなんです
いわゆる道徳的な判断
きちっとしているならば
人格的な判断 きちっとしている人は
財産には自動的に恵まれています
例えば人格者には仕事がないってことないんですよ
会社でもクビにする場合
先にクビにするのは人格はない
信頼できない人なんですよ
それで日常生活の中でも
例えば優れてる性格 卑しい性格知ってる人はどんどんどんどん自分の人格を優れてるようにするでしょ
だからまあお金っていうのは勝手に入るんですよ
そう言えなくはないです
うん  だけど まあなんとなく貧乏だけど
で 問題は ではその人には経済能力がないんですかと
ただ 私は嫌だと そんなものは仕事したくないんだと言って
道徳的なひったなき方するんであって
自分で放棄しているんであって
生活 仕事をしたら あんたにはもうクビ
あんただったらすぐクビになるんだよってことじゃないんです
だから あの 一応道徳的な能力ある人はだいたいではなくて
それは決まってます 仏教の道徳の世界ではね
いわゆるこの 何と言いますか
バカ掃除機とかというと立場が成り立たないんですよ
まあこれから説明しますけど
私はそれが言いたかったんです
あの 今出したポイントをね
本当は成り立たないと
いわゆる人格は素晴らしい
きちんと善悪は知っている
決して間違っていることはしません
何を言っても どんな行動したっても
全部すばりと正しいと
でも貧しくて貧乏で食いにも困っているんだよということはありえない
で まあそれだけは まあこちらで
もしかするとそのポイントだと思いますよ
言いたがっているのはお釈迦様も
だから私たちから見れば
やっぱりもう一種類ぐらいはいたっても悪くないと
ちょっと論理的にはそうなっちゃいますけど
論理といえば論理は論理で
事実は事実とするのはそれまた一つ
仏典のとこポイントなんですね
普通の単純理屈で考えれば種類成り立つんですよ
そこでわざとお釈迦様は一つ省いているんです
それは道徳って何なのかと教えてあげるためなんです
それで この仏教はすべて無常だとかね
執着は捨てなさいよと言うんだからといって
この まあ愚かな人々は
仏教は成長にも反対 経済成長にも反対とかね
いい加減なことを言う
どこにも反対とは書いてないんですけど
執着するなだけに巻かれて言ってるだけのことで
豊かになってはあかんぞとかね
そう言ってないんですよ
もうものすごい脱俗の豊かな人々は出家したんだけど
全部財産捨てて 家にみんな財産捨てて出家しなさいと
そんなことは言ってないんですね
だからこの人々のこのまあいい加減な解釈で
仏教はすごい迷惑しています
で 在家生活しながらするならば
金儲けるのは当たり前の仕事なんですね
金儲けなかったらどうやって生きてるんですかね
仕事をするのは当たり前のことなんですね
仕事をしなきゃ生きていられないんですね
何らかの形で仕事しなくちゃいけないんですよ
地球上では仕事をしないと生きていられるわけじゃないんですね
だから仕事っていうのはいろいろですから
給料もらうだけのことは仕事っていうわけじゃないんですね
私が言いたいのは 動物さえちゃんと仕事をしているんですよ
仕事をして食べてるんです
私は野生動物の中で一人も見たことがない
自分もない 誰かが配るまで餌を配るまでじっと待っているというね
野生動物はそういうふうに待っていません
誰かが餌を持ってくるでしょうと
ホームレスみたいに だから野良猫にしたっても
お腹が空いたらどこへでもね
ちゃんとそれ倒しちゃって
何か食べ物あるんではないかと探してるんですよ
それが動物みたいな仕事なんですね
鳥にしたっても あっちこっち枝から枝へ飛んで餌を探す
それなりに工夫する それなりに苦労もする
だからいろいろ苦労して
自分で餌を取って食べている
それで人間もそれなりに自分の仕事をちゃんとして仕事して食べているのが普通なんですね
ですから それを否定するということはありえないでしょうに
それはもうブッダは否定するわけでもないんです
逆に言っているのは すごい厳しく
この借りを付けて食べるなよと
人に付けなんかは付けるなよと
一番嫌だと この借金とか借りがあることはね
あの人に借りがある この人に借りがあるとか
ものすごいもう品のない生き方だと
だから在家としてはもう不幸だと
例えば いろんな人になんとかお願いする
またなんとかなんとかお願いする
お願いするはいいんだけど
自分もそれなりにその人にいろいろ協力してあげたりはしない場合はそれでそのうちになっちゃうんですね
そういう生き方は良くないんだと
それはこのアナンスカという言葉がございまして
借りのないことの幸福だと
負債ない生き方は だから負債がない生き方自体も幸福だとは言ってます
ですから まあちゃんとして生きてみなさいというのは
お釈迦様ははっきりは言ってるんです
それはブッダの言葉は使わないんだから
もうあまりうまくいってないだけのことで
本当に仏教の国々の人々がブッダの教えをよく聞いてしっかりと生きてるんだったら
負けませんよ この地球のこの競争の
だから我々の場合は どこかでちょっとけしからんところやらね
もういけないところやらいろいろあるんで
性格的に そこら辺で世界のこのもう生きるか死ぬかっていう競争で負けちゃうんですね
仏教の場合 負けるはずがないんですよ
我々仏教の人は敵も作れませんし
競争で腰抜けて逃げることもしませんし
競争はするんだけど 敵は作れません
勝負だったら勝つようにする
勝負だから だからといって相手は敵ではありませんと
そうするとその人は潰せないんだからね
だからそういう手段というよりは
生きる方法を教えている世界なんですね
だからジャータカ物語一つ数珠に出ましたけど
菩薩が象使いとして生まれ変わって
王様の象たちの面倒を見ているんですね
一つの大臣クラスですけどね
で それで一人が弟子入りするんですね
弟子入りした人が まあそれなりに一生懸命勉強する
で 菩薩は全ての技をね
総使いに対して何一つも隠すことなく
秘密なく全部その弟子に叩くんですね
教えてあげる で 教えてあげたところで
先生はもう君ももうそれで一人前だと
ということで 先生の仕事は自分が育てた弟子だから
それから一人社会人として生活しなくちゃいけないで
それで先生が紹介してあげないとね
この人はもうよくできている人やと言って
もう社会人は自分だからね
言ってまあ 象の仕事というのは王のところしかないんだからね
一応王様に面会する時は弟子も連れて行ったんです
言って王様に実は今日私の弟子を紹介したいんだと王様に言って
まあこの人は弟子にして
これぐらいの間で勉強して
もう今完全に勉強終わってるんだと
もう一人前だと ですから王様よろしくお願いしますと言ったら
先生に聞くんですね そうですか
あんたと同じぐらいもうテクニック持ってますかと
その通りですと では雇いましたと
給料はまあ君の半分にしますと
何でもない 給料は君の半分にします
と言って 王様って忙しいんだから
それで終わり 話は 言って弟子と先生は家に帰ったら弟子がえらい不満なんですね
すごい不安不満 ただ なんでそんな不満です
私 先生それは不公平ですよと
私の能力ってのは先生の能力と同じでしょうにと
だったら給料同じ給料払うのは当たり前ではないかと
私は給料にはすごい不満ですよと
あ そう じゃあ王様に言ってみますと
言って また次の日先生がね
言って王様に先生 実は弟子はちょっと不安を持ってますと
能力は平等なのになんで給料は平等じゃないかという不安を持ってるんだと
そしたら弟子も一緒に連れて行って
先生はそう認めませんから
王様も だったら競争っていうかね
ちゃんと競争して 本当に能力平等かないかと試さなきゃダメですよと
言ったら あんた競争しますか？と
弟子もやってみますと先生と戦うんだって
そんなことなく すぐ まあ普通の世界だったらね
インド文化だったらそんなこと絶対やりませんよ
先生に向かって  いくら先生の方が能力は弟子の方が能力は上であろうともね
先生に対してはそんなことはしませんしね
やりましょうと 言ったら王様もこれは変だからね
とにかく 国の人々にもね
集まるようにして ではこの日にちでやりますということで
と言ったっても次の日なんです
次の日やりますと 言って
これで帰ったら先生がもう落ち込んじゃったんです
もう弟子と戦うのはもうかっこ悪いでしょうに
落ち込んで でも菩薩ですからね
どうしようかと で 負けたくはない
だから弟子に負けちゃうと
ものすごい自分の立場がね
大臣クラスの仕事をしているでしょうし
これ弟子にも負ける人だと思っちゃうとね
それですごく良くないし
まあ世の中の まあもう経験というのはいろいろ様々のことやと
まあ私は教えられるものは全部教えられたんだと
ということで まあ負けるわけにはいきません
それでも ということで
一晩で自分が象に別なことを教えちゃったんです
一晩で だからそれ一晩では普通はできません
僧侶会の場合は これは時間かかりますよ
たとえ何でも で 何のことなく
次の日 二人とも自分の象を連れて
まあこの試験場に行くんですね
行ったら まあどこ普通に
まああらゆる まあ立てやら回れやら座れやら
もう前に進め いろんなもう技をね
もう見せるんですね どう見たっても
もう全部ごぶごぶ すぐに踊れと言ったら
もう弟子の象もきちんと踊るわ
先生の象もきちんと踊るわ
それでまあギリギリまで弟子が自分の能力を出して出して
もうそれでもう全部ネタ切れってことになっちゃったんですね
それで全部終わったら
あの先生いきなり象に前に進めと言ったんです
言ったら 象がジリジリと後ろに行くんです
そしたら 後ろに下がれと
言ったら前に来る 立てと言っちゃったら
もうしゃがみ込んじゃったんです
座れと言ったら立つんです
それで全部逆にやることを教えちゃったんです
一日で だからまあ それはまあ
象と心は通い合ってるんだから
それは長い間の経験で
この馬鹿にはそれないんですね
ただテクニックを勉強してもらっただけでね
それでもものすごい恥かれちゃって
まあジャータカ物語では
まあ国民が怒って殺しちゃったんだと
こいつはもう仕事をしたという
もう性格が悪い人だから
もういてはいけないということで
それはどうかわかりませんですけどね
だからそのストーリーで何言ってるんですかって
この仏教のどことなんですよ
競争だったら負けないということなんです
チャレンジだと 試験を受けたら
たとえバカな試験であろうとも
落胆する必要はないんです
後で否定使ってもいいんですけど
やるんだったらもうちゃんとやるっていうことも
一つやっぱり仏教的な考え方なんですね
だから先生は親切に素晴らしい先生で
弟子に 弟子を一人前にしてあげて
仕事も探してあげて もうすごくすくすくと成功して幸福になって欲しがったんですね
そのことを全部逆転したんですね
それで弟子のことを一生懸命心配するんだからといって
弟子がでは先生競争ですと言ったら
負けてためるかと その場合も負けない
というとこは決して悪いことじゃないんですね
ですから やっぱり力比べになったら勝つの当たり前であって
負けるために競技に出る人がいないでしょうに
だったらもともと出なきゃいいでしょうに
だから競争についてもと同じことなんですよ
仏教では儲かってはいけないと言ってるのは
言ってはないんで そんなことはね
そう言う人はいますけどね
まあいろいろまあ金に欲は出しちゃいけないんだと言ってはいけない
言いながら商売店を開くと
言って それで人がこれくれない
持ってきなさいとかね
それは仏教が認める商売じゃないんです
店を開いたということは
利益を取って商売すること
それちゃんとやるのは仏教的なんです
で ただであげませんよと
これは商売品やと ちゃんとお金払えと
だから仏教徒だから 誰かが物が必要ですけど
お金がもうないし 例えばもう人がいて
お腹が空いて でも食べるご飯を買うお金もないし
それだったら自分で寄付として
どうぞこれ持ってご飯食べてくださいとねというふうに言うんですけど
それは商売ではありません
それは別な働き ですから
店開くんだったら商売繁盛するのは当たり前で
もし何か競技に出たら
もう一になるために頑張ってみるのは
それは常識で当たり前です
だからそれは仏教は否定していないんです
ジャータカ物語の中でそういうことはちゃんと入ってるんです
菩薩は負けません どこを見せたって
菩薩っていうのは仏教徒がの最上の生き方なの
結局は ジャータカ物語
お釈迦様は先生に本当にそんな象でいたんですか
馬でいたんですかとかね
そういうフィクス作る人々は
それは自由で勝手に作ってもいいんだけど
彼らはブッダのポイントをすっ忘れてるだけのことです
だから品物を運ぶんだけど
もう穴があって中身は落ちてるんですね
だから我々は中身を大事にする
だから我々にとってはお釈迦様は先生が生まれていたってもいなくたってどうでもいいんです
そこで最上の仏教徒としての生き方説明しているんですね
ジャータカ物語の中で
裁判があるわ まぁ不倫もあるわ
もういろんなことどれでも出てくるわ
ジャータカ物語の中で
その中でいつでも菩薩役がずっとあるんですね
その菩薩役は 仏教徒がその場合はどうするべきかということなんです
ブッダの教えを信仰する人はどうするべきかと
だからお釈迦様は先生物語
時によって牛にもなるし
時によって馬にもなるし
象にもなるし もう修行者にもなるし
いろいろ役をやってます
いろんな役をとって まぁこういう社会状況では
仏教徒はどんな態度をとるべきかということだけ説明している
まぁとにかく競争する話はずっとたくさんあります
どんな競争においても菩薩は勝ちます
そこで競争をかけた相手がちょっと品が悪いとかね
ちょっとこれは競争する立場ではないと思ったら
相手を散々けなしたりまでする
まぁです 例えば今言ったストーリーでは
あの 弟子が殺されるんですよ
いわゆる もう権利がない
社会からあんたは取り消しと
消しちゃう ということは
競争はいいんだけど これやってはいけない競争なんです
先生と 自分を一人前にしてくれた先生と競争する
これするんだったら もう人間失格っていうことで
だから人間失格っていうことは殺しちゃったと言った方が簡単だから
そうやってるでしょうと思います
で 他の場合はただからかって終わっちゃうと
一番お釈迦様が 菩薩がこの知恵を働かせた物語が
あのデーヴァダッッタ物語というジャータカ物語の最後に出てくる物語
すっごい長いストーリーで
まぁそこでいつもでも競争
知恵の知恵比べ 王様に年上のアドバイスをする知識人が四人がいる
ブラマン人が これ菩薩はまだまだ子供
子供ですけど えらい知識あるんだっていうことを王様が知って
その子供を自分でもらいたいんですね
家から お母さんから 自分でもらって自分で育てたいんですよ
だから自分が育てた子が自分でアドバイスすることになったら
もうすごく気楽にアドバイスくれるし
ブラマン人が時々態度でっかいし
いろんなもうもうからくりもやっちゃうし
王様もすごく気がいいわけじゃないんですね
でもこの四人の年上のブラマン人たちが
もう知ってます この子すごい鋭い能力を持ってるんだと
来たならば自分立場がないんだ
どうせ子供でしょうし
だから可愛がってくれるし
だからもう子供の言うことを聞いちゃうではないかということで
もうもう蹴っちゃうんですね
まだまだまだまだ青いんだから
もっと調べましょう もっと調べましょうとかね
それでいろいろ質問を出したりする
全部答えると 一番ものすごい面白いエピソードがあるんだけど
王様の庭のこの水 ちょっと池があって
池の中にすごい光り輝いているこの宝石一つ見えるんですね
ものすごく見たら もう宝石一つ
それではこれは取らなくちゃいけないと
言って みんなにこの池にあるこの宝石取ってくださいと
言ったら このバラモン
林居人が何でもアドバイスする人だからね
言って さすが まあここら辺にあるんだからね
で いろんな工夫して取ろうとするが見つからない
どうしようかと 言ったら
この知識人たちが水を全部出しちゃえばいいでしょうと
すぐ見つかるんだからと
水を全部出しちゃったんですね
宝石は見つからない それでまた水入っちゃうでしょうし
まだ見えると あ やばいと
で また水出したらダメですよと
水を出せ 泥まで全部もう
取ってみたんです 宝石はない
どんどんどんどんまた水が入ってきて
また一定になってくる
また宝石見えると みんな困っている
それでその時は菩薩がもう宮殿に子供で生活しているんですね
そしたらもうそれを見て
君 あの先生たちがね えらい困っているんですよと
言ったら もう菩薩が言って
そんなことなく水の中に宝石見えるんで
見えるし 知ってるんだから
この水が抜けたら無いと
ということは これは映ってるだけ
すぐわかってるんですね
だからなんのことはなく
ちょっとカッコつけて
そこら辺で見たら もう木の上で
まあどこに映ってるかとわかってね
で なんか誰か来てくださいと
言って あんたね この木を登って
このカラスが巣作ってるんだからね
そこをちょっと調べてこいと
で それする前に これは不思議な宝石やと
言って この洗面器一つ持ってこいと
ただ洗面器一つ持ってきて
そちらに水を入れてそこに置いて
見てください 王様 洗面器の中にありますから
この宝石はと では取ってくださいと
水見える 池よりは簡単だから
そうやってちょっとからくりもありますね
それは競争だからね あの四人が頭が悪いと
自分の方が頭がいいと
それは見せるところでしょうに
ですから わざわざ洗面器に水を入れてあげて
そこでまた宝石見させて
だからこの連中はそれぐらいの理屈もわかってないんだと
ですから 王様 この木の上にありますからね
取ってくださいと言ったら
人が登ったら カラスの巣の中に
このカラスが何か持ってきて
もうカラス何でも拾っちゃいますからね
光るものも好きでしょうしね
それ見たら もうそこが宝石を見つけたんだと
やっぱり王様はさすがお前が頭いいなということで
そういう一つのエピソードがある
そういうエピソードもずっとたくさんあります
この物語の中に だから仏教はもう別にもう負けるっていうね
まあ能力が向こうにあって負ける
あれはしょうがないことで
まあ競争に出る場合は自分が負ける必要はないんです
競争するんだからって
相手を敵に回すなよっていうことは
相手は敵ではありません
それから憎しみ 嫌みも必要ないんですね
ですから 仏陀はこの 在家の人々は商売するっていうのは普通当たり前の常識で
それで仏教は商売するんだったらもうかるようにしなさいと
損するんだったらあんたバカやと
赤字だったらね もうアホだと
そんな平気で言うんですよ
商売はしてるんだけど
赤字ばっかしやと だったら目がないんだよと
で それがなんで商売赤字になるかというと
道徳がないんです そこがポイントなんです
なぜ商売はうまくいかない
なぜ金融 巨大な金融機関でも倒産するんでしょうかというと
道徳がないんですよ ただ
これにこれぐらいお金
これにこれぐらいお金を入れただけで儲かるわけじゃないんですよ
儲かることは道徳から儲かるんですよ
だからこの道徳ことあるということがとっても必要な
それが命綱になっているんですね
例えば まあちょっと威張って店をやっていると
決してお客さんが来ないでしょ
道徳がないんですよ 白黒はっきりしていない
何か悪い 何か正しいってわかってない
時々お客さんが来て いろいろわがまま言ったり
いろんな嫌なことをしたりしますよ
でも商売してる人は まあそんなあんたはもう買わないんだったら文句言わないで帰れとはしたことは言わないでしょうに
そこら辺で忍耐強く 私は商人で
この人はもう買わないんだからと言ったっても
もうあれやこれやと言うと
ああ そうですね そうですねとか
まあどうぞどうぞご覧になってくださいとかね
また来てくださいとかね
そういう風にするその謙虚
それ道徳でしょ それで
ああ 嫌な こんな商売なんかやりたくない
毎日文句ばっかり 人が来て
わがままばっかりで 言いたい放題なこと
なんでそんなことやらなくちゃあかんかといったら
商売終わりです ですから
まあちょっと銀行屋だからといって自慢も高慢あって
まあ政権はいくらでも政府は銀行から
もう銀行や金融関係から政治家に賄賂
お金入るんだから まあ政府からいくらでも我々にお金くれるんだぞとかね
と言ったりして もうやったらもう倒産と
どんな大きな組織であろうが
もうすぐ倒産する ですから
株に手を出すたっても
ただ出す手を出しただけで儲かるわけないでしょうに
欲出ちゃうと負ける ただ出す手を出しただけで儲かるわけないでしょうに
欲出ちゃうと負けるではなくて
ちゃんと判断して 何が正しいか
何が悪いか 世の中の状況はどうでしょうかとかね
今どんな品物をよく売れるでしょうかとかね
どんな会社が技術を持ってるんでしょうかとかね
例えば NTT 株買うか
KDD の株買うかというと
私は KDD を勧めますけど
なぜかというと  NTT の方が態度でかいというところが今までありましたし
それだったら赤字になるんですよ
だからそこで決める決め手は何ですかね
道徳ですよ  KDD と NTT はすごい大きい会社であるっていうことじゃないんです
日本の言葉で腰が低いとか謙虚だっていうのも
そのそこに儲かるためにっていうのが
そういう商品が我慢をしたり
サービスをしたりするのは
なんか利益を得るためっていうように自分も思ってるし
商売する人が それからお客の方もそう思ってるわけですよ
だけれども 本当はそうじゃなくて
本当に道徳的にやることが利益につながるんだよっていう風に思えて
商売すればもしかしたら
楽ですよ 楽で儲かるんですよ
逆に儲かるのかもしれませんね
ですから 今おっしゃっている通りに
儲かるためにすっと腰が低くするのは精神的にすごいストレスなんですよ
本当は態度でっかいんですけど
商売に携わるんだから
すごく腰が低くしている
それでお客さんも知っている
商売だからそういうふうにしなくちゃあかんやと
そうするとお互いに信頼関係が結局はない
お客さんが信頼していない
結局は それで それはいいんだけど
品物買ってくれれば 逆に商売する人がものすごい精神的にストレスかかっちゃって
で イライラして奥さんに当たる
子供に当たるとかね あるいはもう酒に溺れると何とかになっちゃうんで
だからあまりうまくいかないんですね
それで道徳やと これが商売ではなくて
これ自分の人格であって道徳やと
だから商売が商売抜きの時でも
まあ私はいつでもその時は冗談で
私は商売が商売柄いつでも腰が低いんだから
どうぞどうぞ みんなにいつでもその自分が腰が低いこと
ありがたい価値だと見る
自分が正直であることは
商売よりもありがたい価値であると
だから道徳に価値があるんだと
そろそろと商売なんかはもう気にせでももう勝手に儲かると
それも日本のことわざで
お金っていうのはもう勝手に入る問題よとかね
あるいはお金っていうのはすごい仲間が好きやと
ですから あるところにしか行かないんだと
という それも日本人が経験で言ってることでしょ
で 例えばお金ない人はいくら賭け事にお金出しても
いくら競馬に行ってももう儲かりませんと
お金はもうすごい寂しがり屋だからね
ない人のところに行かないんだと
よく見ると お金ある人っていうのはお金の儲かる仕方
性格を持ってるんですよ
だからお金が勝手に入るということなんです
もともとそういう性格だから
お金がそちらに残っていて
そういう人が生きている上で
自動的にどんどんどんどん金が入ったり入ったりする
ですから この商売の秘訣は道徳にあるんです
成功の秘訣も道徳にあるんです
で 政界のプリンスはなんでプリンスでなくなったかというと
頭が悪いからじゃないでしょ
すごい知識人でしょ 技術はあります
政治家として小さい時からあるもの
それでも外国ですごい勉強もして
まあかなり立派な方で
知識人として政治家として
それは立派な方ですよ
加藤さんは でももう辞任して
もう隠れなくちゃいけなかったと
全てパーになっちゃったんですよ
で 杉森さんにあたってもね
すごくもうバリバリで
もう明るくていい人でしたけど
どこかでちょっと道徳が壊れちゃって
もう白バイに乗せて帰ってくるんですね
だから政治家の歴史をムンと調べてみても
みんな不明になったのは
全てなくなって失ったのは
どこかで道徳を壊した時なんですよ
例えば 一千万円賄賂取ったんだからといって一千万払っちゃえばその人が億単位で計算している人々でしょ
日本では億万長者じゃなきゃ政界には入れてくれないんだから
だからそんな一千万円
五百万円って何ですかね
それ そういう人々にとっては一日でぶつかっちゃうでしょうに
だから五百万円をちょっと不正が見つかりましたと
はい わかりました じゃあ一千万円払います
払っちゃえば払ってもしょうがないでしょ
一千万払ってもダメはダメなんですね
ですから 道徳っていかに厳しいかと
いかに我々の命に関わるかということは理解してほしいんですよ
だから習熟というんですか
アクセスは道徳なんです
道徳の周りで道徳のアクセスで世界は回っているんです
そういうわけで 道徳を否定して無視している社会は
たとえ豊かであろうとも
それは泡のようなもので
一時的なもので 泥の沼の上に作った建物のように
いつ倒れるかわからない
土台がしっかりしていない
そこで道徳的に正直に生きていると
何の心配することもない
もう必要な 例えば大金は要らんと思っても
入ってきます ですから
例えば道徳のみを考える人が
まあ自分でいろいろ それでも人々に何かサービスしてあげると
お金を考えてないんだと
思っても結構損はしません
決して 例えばこういうことを考えましょう
子供たちにちょっと塾みたいなものを作ってあげましょうと
ある まあ教育も持っている人が教えるのにすごい能力もあるし
かなり抜群の能力あるし
だからといって給料で仕事したくないんだと
自分にはそれなりに食べるものがあるんだと
もうなんとかちょっと食べていればいいやと
それよりは 子供たちは困っている時はしっかり育てなくちゃいかんと
来てくれ 私は無料で教えてあげるぞと
まあたくさん来ると困りますからということをちょっと私見とかあったっていいんですけど
それで一生懸命教えちゃうと
それでその人はすごく儲かるんですよ
たとえそれなりに 全面的に全て無料であろうとも
それはもう別に それはすごく普通なことで
やってみたらちゃんと学費を取って
もしかすると塾やってる人よりは気楽で収入の方が多いかもしれません
そうすると親たちが強引にお金出していくんですよ
強引 それこそ約束もないんですね
これぐらいあなたに払ってるんではないかと
それもない それはもう気持ちですから
どうぞどうぞということでね
気持ちですから 別に約束はないので
それからは ですから やっぱり前におっしゃったように
経済的にはもう興味ない人が
でも道徳の目はしっかり持っているんだったら
あの目があるんですよ
結局は ただ桑で閉じているだけ
目は一時的に閉じたっても見えることは見えるんだからね
我々もたまたま何か明確に見る場合は一つ目を閉じるでしょう
例えば何かこれまっすぐかとかね
曲がっているかとか 例えば何か何かに的を当てて撃ったりするときは
一つ目を閉じるんだから
ですから まあそういうことで
だからお釈迦様もそこら辺はちゃんと我々に悟ってほしいんだから
一個しか目がない人にとっては道徳は知らんバカやと言っているんですね
そこで 二つの目を持っている人は
二つとも道徳も経済能力も持っているんだと
道徳的な知識あって経済能力ない人はもう取り消し
それはありえないということにして
ですから 世の中ではね
ものすごくみんな苦しんでいるし
苦労して商売しているし
それはもうほとんど道徳に欠けているんだから
そういう問題は出てきます
だから まず商売に必要なのは信頼でしょう
信頼できないんですから
だから あちらにお金を預けたらよろしいか
こちらに わからないでしょうね
信頼できないでしょう
どれほど人を騙されているんですかね
お互いに倒れるでしょう
そこでお金 人のお金をだまして 100億単位で儲かったっても
その人のお金にならないし
もう法律違反だからね
あげた人にも返ってくるお金はないし
どうなったかわからない
なんとかというすごい大きなデパート潰れたでしょう
SOGO 簡単でしょう
原因は もう社長の道徳的な生き方が危うくだからでしょう
SOGO みたいは何のことなく倒れますよ
そういう社長の道徳がなくなっちゃうと
だからいかにすごいかと
この道徳のパワーっていうのは
そこで松下の何とかさんとかね
本まで書いていろいろ人格者でしょ
潰れなかったですね 人格者だから
今もそれほど問題はないしね
そういうわけで このいかなる商売にしたっても
道徳はもう欠かせないということになっちゃうんです
それだけはもう捨てるとすべて捨てたことになります
この世の中の幸福も捨てて
死後の幸福も捨てている
ですから 豊かになりたい
商売繁盛したいと 幸福になりたいと
たった一つ教えてくださいと
方法と言えば 道徳を守れと
それだけ そこで仏教の道徳の見方は結構幅広いんです
[背景音楽]結構幅広い
ものすごい幅広く見ているんですね
ですから この世の中でいいといいと思っているものは
僕はいいとは思ってないんですよ
例えば付き合いで酒飲むでしょ
それは日本だからしょうがないとか
僕はそうということはあるんです
そこで潰れる人はないかと
酒飲んで酔っ払って契約して大丈夫かと
よく潰れると思いますけどね
よく問題が来ると思いますけどね
ですから 酒飲んで酔っ払って商売の決めるんじゃなくて
しっかりした日 頭で まあ昼とかね
朝とか まあ午後と集めて
きちんとデータのやり取りをやって
いかがでしょうかと それでまあはい
成立 相談成立と握手して
まあそれから友達みたいな感じで
行って 行って酒飲んだり
ご飯食べたってもいいんだけど
それで相手の会社の人に
まあものすごいどこかのすごい高級な何とか何とかところで
料亭とか何とかところで接待したっても
もうバレバレでしょう？お互い様に
だからそこからも不正働いてるんですね
行く人々も誰かのお金でタダで食うという気持ちで行くし
それで贅沢にタダで食うと
それ自体人格というか品がないでしょうね
会社のお金で食ってるんだからね
だからもうネクタイつけて偉そうにいるんだけど
本当はすごい惨めな生き方している
で それでもバレバレで
それでお互いに見栄のね
上辺だけの挨拶とかね
それで社員たちはね 相手の会社の人を楽しませるためにバカなことをやるわ
ふざけたことをやるとかどうか
それまた人格はもう丸潰れてるでしょうに
みんなもう立派な男たちでしょうに
そこまでするんですかね
ちょっと金儲かるために
だから道徳ないんだからでしょ
全て 道徳あったらもう料亭でまあもう酒でも飲みながら商談
いえ これはちょっとそちらの会社には接待したいのは山々ですけど
だからこれは大事な商売だから
しっかり判断してほしいんだからね
我々にとっては大事なお客さんだから
お客さんには迷惑かけたくないんだよと
ですから三時に来てくださいと
三時に伺いますよと で
三時に伺って まあこういうことで
こういうことで では相談して
じゃあでは今日七時半でいかがでしょうかと
後でご飯食べ そうすると別に売買でも何でもないでしょうに
惨めでもないではないでしょうに
相談成立したお祝いでしょうに
だからちょっと道徳崩れると
もう人格的にも惨めになる
それからまあ まあ私もあんまりもう社会のことはね
日本の社会のことをあまりというとことこじゃなくて
まあよく知りませんですけど
まあ知ってるのはそこら辺ちょっとちょっと店やらね
やってるだけですけどね
やっぱり惨めでビラを配る人と
楽しくてやってやるぞという気持ちでビラを配る人と二種類いるでしょうに
だからまあもう何でもヘッドフォンでも聞きながら踊りながらなんとか店のビラを配る
そうするとそいつだから取りたくもなるしね
見たらまあ自分には行けないんだけど
まあ行ってあげたってもいいんじゃないかという気持ちは生まれますよ
私にしたっても そうすると自分の人格を落としてないんですよ
例えばすごく あの まあこれは素晴らしい店でございますけど
いかがでしょうかとかねと言ったっても
ああそうということで
これ面白い店ですよとかね
面白い店ですよという風に言ったら
ああそうって それで行きたくなるような気持ちが出てきます
だから まあこれそれも道徳であって
これ人格ですよ それはこちらでこのパーリ語でこのヒーナパニーテダンメ
卑しくなる性格と優れた人間になる性格をはっきりしなさいよと
ヒーナパニーテ ヒーナっていうのは卑しい
パニータっていうのは優れている
ですから まあ社会生活する時でも
やっぱり自分の人格を守らなくちゃいけない
みっともないことやらね
恥ずかしくなることやら
後で後悔することやら
それはたとえ社長に言われたってもやりませんという立場をとるとかね
だからよく見えますよ
たとえ社長であろうと
普通の社員たちがしっかり道徳持っていると
社長に文句を言うんですよ
それはダメですよとかね
こんなことを社長に任せちゃったら
もうどうなるかわからないんだから
もう黙っていなさいとかね
私たちはやりますよとかいう場合もありますよ
そうすると社長があんた方は普通の社員で
社員の言うんで何やってることは言えません
こちらはしっかり道徳を持っていると
人格を持っていると だから人格を持つとか
すごくすごいことで ものすごいしっかり生きていられるんですね
とにかく惨めで生きることは僕は認めません
とにかくはっきりと 例えば歩く金がある人は自分の家でお手伝いさんを雇うと
あんたお手伝いさんではないかって惨めですよ
その人は向こうはでっかな態度取ったよね
でっかな態度を取らないと
私はこの時間からこの時間まで仕事するんだからと
だから何よと そういうふうに自分の立場を取っちゃえば
それだけのことで 逆にまあ仕事仕事っていうことじゃなくて
自分を雇った人に対して
まあよく雇ってくれましたと
というところで信頼できるように仕事をすると
ちゃんと自分のサービスはきちんとしてあげると
相手が満足するようにしてあげると
そうするともう仕事はずっと続くんでしょうに
どんどんお手伝いさんの格が消えちゃうんですよ
友達になるんです  そんなもんなんです
それでこのまた道徳のリストをもう一度見てみます
このお釈迦様はたくさん言葉で
この経典のポイントはたくさん言葉使ってます
道徳のために 障害のために 2つの言葉で
ない財産を作る ある財産を増える
これだけで終わっちゃうんです
でも道徳になってくるとたくさん言葉使ってます
まずあるのはクサラクサラダンマ
で クサラっていうのは
この英訳する場合は違う言葉使うんですね
まあ英語の単語を忘れちゃって考えてるんです
これどういう意味になるんでしょうかね
スキルフル スキルフルというね
まあ匠ということですけどね
クサラっていうのは で
まあ匠っていう アクサラっていうのはそうではないと
ですから かなり広いんですよ
善悪ということでもないんです
匠かないかと だから匠って何かに比較して対照して出てくるものでしょ
何もやることなかったら匠って成り立たないでしょうにね
何もしない場合はね ですから幅広いんですよ
英語だったらスキルということでね
スキルまた何か日本語でも使ってるみたいですね
あれがちょっとニュアンスが違うと思いますね
ある分野で何かに ね だからそれはスキルじゃないんですよ
それはまあ経験と言った方がいいんですけどね
ですから 日本語でスキルと言っていることは
英語で言うスキルではないんですね
スキルっていうのは まあ日本語で匠なんですね
匠と言えば それだけでは全然意味がないんです
匠って何なのかと だから何かに対して
何何かに対して匠であるということになりますから
どんなものにも当てはめられます
スキルというのは経験ではないんですよ
だから匠ということの経験ではないんですよ
たとえ経験があっても
匠がない人はいるんですよ
この人はこの仕事を 10年もやってますけどという
だから匠ってまだ別でね
まあまあ上手というぐらいのことでね
すぐまあ誰々がこうっていうことでね
[背景音楽]ですから
料理であろうか 掃除洗濯であろうが
商売であろうが もうどんなことにあろうとも巧みに巧みということは必要だろうと
それはクサラとアクサラ
だから巧みでないというのは下手で
もう間違いだらけで 失敗だらけで
もう損ばっかりするということなんですね
だからそれも仏教は道徳に入れているんですね
で なんで道徳にそれ入れたかというと
これ 巧みという人こそ
俗世間でも成功 成功して
出家したならば悟りも得られるんだ
だからそういう上手な人は仏教にとても上手ですよ
成功しますという意味なんですね
だから仏教ではね まあ金儲かりたいと思ったら
これは上手に成功する
私は金ではなくて知識儲かりたい
知識人になりたいと言ったら
ちゃんと知識人に一人前の知識人になる
いえ 知識人にもなりたくない
道徳を育てたい だったら一人前の道徳者にもなる
では出家したいと だったら一人前の出家者になる
修行したい だったら成功して悟ると
さて 何やっても成功するという
そのノウハウを そのテクニックはクサラ・アクサラにしているんですね
だから仏教にとってはそれは一つのモラルの中なんです
修行にも使うんだから
クサラ・アクサラ で ただ
まあ上手な運転の仕方になってくると
別に道徳に関係ないんですよ
クサラ・アクサラの場合はそんなに経験なくても
まあすぐ分かればいいということで
で 長い間の修行によっても上達する
で それでクサラと言え
それも言えますけどね
でもそれに限っちゃうと
他の人々はなんか切り捨てたことになっちゃうんですね
例えばクサラがない人がね
いて だったら一生懸命修行して修行して
そのテクニックを身につけばいいんです
そこで やがてクサラになりましたと
でももう届かない 何でもしっかりやるぞという人もいますよ
じゃあしっかりやると
それでも経験ない人は下手かもしれませんよ
でも経験ないわりに あんたしっかり頑張ってるんではないかということでしょうに
勉強するのは誰でもやってますけど
上手かないかそれで決めるでしょう
ですから 何でもそれで決めちゃいます
やることなんでもいいんです
決まり手は上手か無いかと
上手だったらあんた幸せになるんだよと
でなきゃダメですよと
そういうことで あの そこはちょっとした知恵だからね
だから脳は誰にでもあるでしょうと
ちょっといじっちゃえば出てきますから
そういうわけで これを使ってるんです
だから生まれつきもう私にはついてないんだっていう文句は言えません
みんな脳 脳細胞持って生まれるんだからね
だからクサラというテクニックは身につけます
ちょっと調べれば身につくんで
あ こうやればいいやと
能力 技術っていうのは向き不向きがあります
大工さんになるか 絵描きさんになるかっていうことは
その人の好みでいいんです
でも たとえ大工さんになろうと
絵描きさんになろうと
上手になってほしい でなきゃ商売にならないと
というぐらいのことです
そこで上手になるということは簡単にできる
それはちょっとした心の心構えです
それで次 サーワッジャ・アナワッジャという言葉があります
サーワッジャ・アナワッジャっていうのは
その場合ははっきりと
あの 罪と善ですよ サーワッジャっていうのはもう罪という
やってはいけない 論ということなんです
その場合ははっきり 例えば嘘をつくなよと
人を騙すなよと はっきりします
クサラ・アクサラははっきりしないんです
上手か無いかと 嘘つくのも下手な人だから
もうクサラな人は嘘つかないんですよ
そこで嘘をつくにしても
上手な人はバレないように嘘をつくと
だからクサラ・アクサラはちょっと働きが違うんですね
だから上手だからといって悪いことを上手にすることを仏教は認めません
やがて悪いことを積み重ねてね
まあもう大変なことになりますから
ですから まずクサラとアクサラがあって
それから悪いことと良いことをはっきり区別する
だからサーワッジャの場合は
嘘をつくことはサーワッジャ
間違っている サーワッジャが間違っているという意味で
まあ泥棒 盗むこともサーワッジャ
間違っている 不正的なことをするのもサーワッジャ
間違っていると アナワッジャっていうのは正しいっていうことで
そこでクサラっていうのは上手と
そこで上手な人は嘘をつくと
もう確かに上手に嘘をつくんだけど
バレないように でもそうすると道徳は逸れているんですね
だから認めません そこで上手な人は間違っていることは絶対しないと
正しいことをすると上手だから
それをまたすごい見事に立派にする
そういうわけで 仏教の用語の場合はクサラ・アクサラ・サワッジャ・ナワッジャはかなり違う意味を持ってます
これ残念な日本訳する場合はどちらでも善悪・善悪になるんです
だから善悪では訳できません
善不善はできますけど
だから善不善と善悪で訳するんですけど
なんかちょっと言葉足らないっていうことはありますね
だから巧みと巧みでないという風に
一応訳はできませんだけどね
そういう理解はクサラ・アクサラ
サワッジャ・ナワッジャは罪と
もうそれ反対の言葉 なんか分からない
まあ善ですね まあ罪と
まあ不罪とか言ったってもおかしいしね
次の言葉はヒーナ・パニータ・ダンマ
それも道徳に入ってますね
で ヒーナ・パニータっていうのは
やっぱりまあ卑しいものと卑しいでないものを区別することなんですけど
まあ俗世間で言えばね
賭け事をするはもうパチンコに溺れるはとか
どう見ても卑しいだからね
まあちょっと人格的にはね
そこをそうやって社会の中でもこれはちょっとみっともないんだね
これはちょっとかっこ悪いとかね
それはちゃんと理解してほしいんですね
ですからそこら辺はもうすごいみんな無責任なんですね
このかっこ悪いこととかっこいいことの区別判断というのは
それはもう人間が思っているかっこいいか悪いというよりも
ちょっともうちょっと違いますけどね
ですからこのヒーナは卑しい
パニータは優れてる それ発揮してますね
それでこの仏道の場合はね
まあまあ例えば怠けるとかね
怠けることは罪かどうか
それ罪ですよと そこまでちょっと言わなくてもいいでしょう
あるいは朝寝坊しちゃったと
あんた罪を犯しましたよと
そこまで言わなくても
でもちょっとあんたかっこ悪いでしょと
そんな毎回毎回朝寝坊してかっこ悪いと
ヒーナ その場合卑しい
罪起こしたよと言わなくてもいいんです
ですから その意味なんです
例えば学校でちょっと声が多すぎやと
あんた声が大きいんだから
もうもう退学やとかね
校則破ったぞとかは言えませんでしょうに
でもあんたちょっとかっこ悪いやと
そんな態度だったら ちょっと将来も危険やということは言えますね
ですからヒーナ・パニータもその意味
その意味で使う もっと難しいんですけどね
で まあよくよく考えられて
なんでかというと 我々はどんどん人格を成長しなくちゃいけない
どんどん良い人間にならなくちゃいけない
どんどん人格的に優れている人格者にならなくちゃいけない
人格者になるためには
自分の心にある卑しいものと優れてるものを区別できないと
それでどんどん人格者にまでなります
だから罪にはなりませんだけど
ちょっとちょっと悪いこのみっともないとこやらね
そこら辺はどんどんどんどん直してみる
最後の思考までみっともない思考もしないというとこまで行く
怒りが生まれてみっともないんだと
かっこ悪いと一人で思う
そんな怒ればっかしで
憎しみばっかしで 私は何の人間かと
かっこ悪い 気持ち悪いと
というふうなことで ちょっとプライドを持って
すごい立派な人間やとことで
怒りなんか憎しみなんか出ていけと
というふうな感じで このひいなっぱ
それで人格が成り立っていくんですね
で 最後の言葉やと思いますけど
カンナ・スッカ・サッパティ・バーゲ・ダンメ
で これはカンナはブラック
スッカはホワイト それでブラックというのは悪であって
この悪の仲間と善の仲間をちゃんと理解しなさいということなんです
だからどういう生き方をすればじりじりと自分の心が悪い方向に行くんかなと
やってること大して悪いことじゃないかもしれませんよ
でもそういうことをやり続けると
どんどんどんどんどんどん行ってしまうかもしれません
それでカンナ・スッカっていう
というのは 例えば兄弟でちょっと喧嘩すると思う
兄弟喧嘩ぐらいどうったことはないんだけど
でも喧嘩もどんどんどんどん慣れっこになっちゃって
もっと刺激欲しくなったりすると
どうなるかわからない
ものすごい激しい喧嘩するかもしれません
もう二度と仲直りできないほど喧嘩するかもしれません
あるいは犯罪まで起こすかもしれません
喧嘩で気が済まないで
相手の兄弟の家にもう放火するところまで行くかもしれませんしね
そうすると 何のことはないんだけど
やってることは黒い方の仲間なんですね
そこは気をつける 我々は別に悪い人じゃないんだけど
悪い人のエージェントたちが心にいるかもしれません
悪のエージェント エージェントからちょっと名刺もらって住所をたどっていったら
もう悪そのものの世界やと
だからそこら辺も考えてほしいと
そういうのは瞑想する
修行する場合は大変に必要なことだから
カンナ・スッカ・ダンマというふうに言ってますね
スッカ・ダンマと また専門的な解釈はものすごいたくさんあります
今したのは一般的な解釈です
それは知ってほしいと
で あの偈もありますけどね
それは日本訳では偈訳してないような感じがします
ナッチェーワ・ボーガ・タター・ルーパ・ナチャ・プンニャーニ・クッバティ・ウベヤット・カリッ・ガホー・アンダッス・ハタ・チャックノー
ナッチェーワ・ボーガ・タター・ルーパ
それなりの財産もない
ナチャ・プンニャーニ・クッバティ
徳を積むこともしない
ろくな財産もない いわゆる能力ない
貧しい 貧乏 それだけじゃない
ナチャ・プンニャーニ・クッバティ
徳も積まない 良いこともしない
ウベヤット・カリッ・ガホー
この人はどちらでも負けますよと
今世でも負けるし 来世でも負けるんだと
アンダッス 目が見えないんだと
ハタ・チャックノー 目が失っているんだと
盲人というよりはもう失明やと
アター・アパーラーヤン・アッカート・エーカ・チャックー・チャ・プッガロー
アター・アパーラーヤン
それから喋りますよ それから語ります
エーカ・チャックー・チャ・プッガロー
一つの目の人について語りましょう
ダンマー・ダンメーナ・サトー・ソー
サトー・ソーってちょっとわからない
サンサットーということが正しいと思います
このスリランカのテキストにサンサットーになっています
ミャンマーテキストでサトー・ソー
それはちょっと意味があってよくない
ですからダンマー・ダンメーナ・サンサットー
ダンマっていうのは良いこと
アダンマというのは悪いこと
ごちゃ混ぜ 良いことも悪いこともして
ボーガーニ・パリエーシで金儲かる
だから手段選ばず金儲かるっていうことなんです
手段選ばず金儲かる人は一つの目の人やと
テイエーナ テイエというのは盗む
クータ・カンメーナっていうのは詐欺
ムサーワーディーナっていうのは嘘
どちらでもいいやと 嘘を言うは
詐欺をやるは 盗むは 何でもいいだから金儲かれればいいんじゃないかと
金儲かる技術は身に付いてます
でも善悪はわからないと
クサラ・ホーティ・サンガートゥン
サンガートゥンはサンガートゥン
カーマ・ボーギー・チャ・マーナヴォ
サンガートゥン もう儲かることだけは上手やと
それからカーマ・ボーギー
まあ欲に溺れているその人がイトー・ソー・ニレアンガン・トア・エーカ・チャックー・ディハンヤと
で 今世では豊かですけどね
泥棒でもして嘘でもつけて詐欺でもやって金儲かってますからね
今世は問題ないんだけど
ニレアンガンと 死んでから地獄に落ちますよと
ですから目一つしかなかったと
今世のこと見える目があったんだけど
来世のこと見える目がなかったと
ディチャック・パナッカーと
それから両目を持ってる人のことを喋ります
セットー・プリサッ・プッガ
その人は偉大なる人やと
ダンマラッデーヒ・ボーゲーヒ
財産は法にのっとって
法にのっとって財産儲かる
ウッターナ・アディガタン・ダナン
それから頑張って努力して
詐欺やるんじゃなくて
ちゃんと努力して財産儲かるんだと
ウッターナ・アディガタン・ダナン
それからダダーディ・セッタ・サンカッポ
得た財産も お布施したり寄付をしたりしてね
欲張りはしないんだと
アッビャッガ・マーナソーナロー
アッビャッガって何でしょうか
アッビャッガ・マーナソー
アッビャッガは これ言葉を壊してますから
ないでしょう おそらく
おそらくこの怒りのことかな
あるいは欲のことかな
どちらかなんです ちょっとちょっと壊してるんだから
これもっと他のテキストを参照しないと意味は取れないんです
アッビャッガ・マーナソーナロー
これアビ・アッガ アッビャッガ
アビッジャーナはアビッジャだからね
まあアッビャッガ 混乱していないという
という意味でも取れますしね
とにかくまあいいや それ抜けます
意味も抜けるって意味なんです
私はそれ納得しませんだから解釈するのを抜けます
[笑い]アッビャッガの意味は辞書では抜ける
抜く でもそれではこの解釈できませんだから
解釈抜くしか方法ないんです
で ダダーディ・セッタ
ダダーディっていうのはお布施をする
すごい素晴らしい智慧
心で 尊い心を持って 私は立派な人だという心を持って
お布施をしたりする それでアッビャッガ・マーナソーナロー
おそらく混乱しない 落ち着いている心っていう意味でしょうと思います
ウペーディ・バッダガントリー
その人はすごい平安なところに至れると
幸福なところに ヤターガンター・ナ・ソーチャティ
死んでから平安なところにいて
そこで困ることを悩むことは一切ないんだと
そこからアンドン・チェ・エーカ・チャックン・チェ・アーラカー・パリワッジャヤー
アンドン 盲人と 一人の目がある人をアーラカー・パリワッジャヤー
全く付き合えるなよと
アーラカーというのは見たら逃げろと
もう簡単に逃げることじゃない
もうもう影も気配見たら逃げろと
付き合えないよと 大変危険やと
もう自分の人生ダメになっちゃうんですよ
だからもう絶対付き合ってはいけない
もう逃げた方がいいんですね
ディチャックン・パナ・セーヴェーテ
この両方の目を持ってる人々と付き合いなさいと
仲良しなさいと セッタン・プリサプカル
その人は偉大なる人間であると
はい 以上です  両方の目を持ってる人ってあんまりいないんじゃないですかね
うん だから楽でしょ そんなたくさん人を付き合わなくてもいいんだから
そういう立派な人一人二人がいて
一人いれば十分ですよ
立派な人が一人に過ぎたってのは
自分の人生でいっぱいになるんだからね
どうでも人々にも もう百人一万人に付き合ったってもね
意味がないし ですから
やっぱり仏教は厳しいんですよ
でなきゃね 社会はね 直せないしね
みんなだらしないんだからね
世の中では本当にみんな金儲かる方法しか知ってないし
それももう手段は選ばずということでしょうね
そういう人付き合って自分そうなっちゃうでしょ
だからもう付き合わなくたってもいいんじゃないかと
道徳知ってる人がいれば
その人はまあ商売やらなくたっても
まあうまいこと教えて
いろいろ教えてくれちゃうしね
そういうことで まあ少ない方が私は楽やと思います
まあそれは冗談で言ったんですけど
本当はまあほとんど少ないことは確かなんですね
[犬の鳴き声]